we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P take a listen to this
voicemail from a guy who's just throwing
out all the right wing Mega red meat
listen to this
and I'm going to say David pack boys a
beta
beta mail what he's saying is David pack
boy is a beta male thank you
okay well vote for the guy go ahead
Jesse Lee Peterson's an alpha male and
he's innocent and
you know Jesse Lee Peterson hasn't to
say Jesse Peterson is innocent
people have come out and said Jesse Lee
Peterson's gay I don't know that
innocent is necessarily the right term
yes he's accused of making advances but
the the term innocent is a weird term to
use and
Joe Biden Hunter Biden prison 2023.
that's a bet I would be willing to take
I am not a betting man
but if someone wants to bet even odds do
hunter or Joe Biden end up in prison in
2023 I will take the no on whatever
Stakes you've got later yeah later uh
this is pretty significant brain rot but
unfortunately at least some of these
people vote it's important we all be
registered and we all participate I have
something super exciting to announce to
you
next Friday December 23rd we have never
done something like this before we're
going to be doing our end of the year
membership Drive oh David but you've
done that before Oh the bonus show where
you want to make money yeah everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
as bad no no no this is different okay
our end of the year membership Drive
it'll be a one day event Friday December
23. it'll be beautifully timed right
before Christmas and during Hanukkah
it's going to be fantastic okay it's
going to be really really good open to
everybody whatever you celebrate or
don't celebrate one day membership Drive
the first month's payment
for people who sign up on that day using
the special coupon code
is going to be donated and then matched
and doubled and we are going to be doing
this through give directly which
actually gives cash to people in extreme
poverty widely known now the best way to
really build industry and community and
allow people to determine for themselves
how best to improve their lives you
don't send shoes you give cash okay so
this is super super exciting Friday
December 23 it's going to be a
membership drive with a great discount
code so you can get a membership but
then that first payment if you pay
monthly it'll be your first payment if
you pay yearly will take a 12th of it
your first month's membership payment
we're not keeping we will donate and
then double it okay I have no idea
whether this will do well or whether it
won't we've never done anything like it
before but I would love for you to
participate it's really easy get on my
mailing list at davidpackman.com
just get on the mailing list
Friday December 23rd you'll get an email
telling you here's the coupon code you
sign up you get the membership we donate
that first payment and double it donate
and double double it unbelievable stuff
excited to do it last thing we've got a
great bonus show for you today we're
going to talk about the new plan to ban
tick tock the plan to ban Tick Tock in
the U.S secondly we've learned that
Brett Kavanaugh hangs out with Matt
Gates why what are they doing is it
appropriate it's not and we will talk
about the pandemic border entry limits
on migrants being set to end next week
what are the implications what are the
uh speculations all of that and more on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access